l'armée française elle s'est donné
quatre à six mois pour quitter le mali
pas question d'accélérer paris ne
tolérera aucun ultimatum assure
aujourd'hui jean castex à l'adresse de
la junte malienne bamako a exigé
vendredi un départ sans délai des 2400
soldats encore déployés sur place
pourtant c'est la france qui est
responsable dans la bouche du premier
ministre gail maïga il a donné un
entretien exclusif à alain foka pour rfi
et france 24
entretien que vous allez à présent
pouvoir suivre et juste après bien nous
en discuterons avec notre reporter cyril
payen qui est à mes côtés et qui a
couvert l'actualité malienne ces
derniers mois pour france24 voici tout
de suite donc cet entretien
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cet entretien
qui reçoit aujourd'hui le premier
ministre chef du gouvernement du mali
monsieur choguel maïga bonjour monsieur
le premier ministre un jour alors j'ai
envie de commencer en disant vous êtes
considéré comme le faucon qui a décidé
de bouter les français hors du mali on
exagère quand on dit ça soit qu'on
exagère nous formons une équipe
chef mais celui qu'on entend le plus et
vous un celui qui parle à la tribune des
nations unies celui qui est sur des
médias c'est vous on n'a pas beaucoup
entendu à ce micro état le président en
parler nous étions beaucoup il donne des
orientations donc je sais plus où moins
de façon précise derrière sa vision de
celui qui pense que la france vous a
lâché en plein vol comme vous l'avez
laissé entendre à la tribune des nations
unies à bandra en plein vol c'est un
militaire dans l'art militaire quand du
cône abandonné en plein combat fait cela
très long mais on a habillé les termes
en parlant de la bonne eau en plein vol
ces officiers ont fait entre 15 et 18
ans
sur le théâtre des opérations militaires
dans le noir ils ont été enlevés
séquestrés par les terroristes pendant
des mois ils ont échappé des embuscades
et lui c'est le commandant des forces
spéciales les opérations allaient
plaider sur le terrain difficile dans
ces deux hommes qui ont vécu dans leur
chair et dans leur âme toutes les
trahisons tous les coups bas toulon
revient beaucoup de leurs propos
monsieur le premier ministre pas quand
vous dites trahison trahison de la part
de la france or la france vous dit nous
sommes venus vous aider ici on n'était
pas venu en 2013 le mali n'existerait
peut-être plus comment peut-on parler
trahison dans ces circonstances graves
et qu'une haute autorité française
des sénateurs des députés
dans des débats on dit clairement il
faut donner l'autonomie autres il faut
un plan d'autonomie que les maliennes du
nord et le sud ne peut pas vivre à la
fédération en fait il voulait diviser le
mal est pas une fédération de 15 mètres
2000 15 quand l'accord pour la paix la
réconciliation du président le lendemain
le mil la défense française ayew lydia
la donne une interview sur rfi vu que
les maliennes du nord et du sud on peut
faire pour vivre ensemble c'est
difficile conclusion on la tire avant
lui au sida que ça soit de gauche ou de
droite aux palmas s'est documenté les
années qui va donner un plat de nouilles
ou le nid des affaires étrangères de
nicolas sarkozy à l'egypte et je les
écoutais j'ai documenté il a dit sur la
chaîne lci
que son dernier voyage
au mali en mars 2012 il a dit à att
qu'il faut donner l'autonomie autres
avec des chefs indépendantistes on dit
que c'est la france qui leur a promis de
diviser le bas du pont ferré métal donc
quand eux après le pays a été envahi et
que notre gouvernail saisi l'état
français ce qui a été convenu pour que
je parle de trahison ce qui a été
convenu la lettre était clair appuyé à
hélier et il n'était pas prévu des
militaires françaises c'est les soldats
maliens qui ont libéré conac a libéré
quant aux lubies de tombouctou arrivée
année fils c'est l'armée française qui
l'a balayé la menace est réelle ça que
l'armée française a empêchés d'entrer
dans qu'ils aient authentique avec kelly
explication commence et expliqué qu'il
ne puisse pas rentrer dans une ville du
mali ils se sont opposé par les armes et
l'ambassadeur de france qui étaient là
ce moment il s'appelait christian oui
pour avoir dit à son gouvernement
vous êtes un teint de faire une faute ce
que vous souteniez ne sont pas le
présentateur ni dans la communauté
traîner dans leur commune tournée vous
discréditez pas avec u2 ou la peur la
relever ça va partir à la remplacer par
l'officier de la dgse d'officiers de
liaison avec les moues remercions
générale de la sécurité intérieure les
services de renseignement
un officier qui vient qui s'appelle
julie personnes c'est lui qui doit
désigner comme ambassadeur on se
souvient la liesse populaire ici lorsque
françois hollande à leur président est
venu ici mon le remercier pour avoir
sauvé le mali neuf ans après qu'est ce
que c'est parce que on demande à l'armée
française de partir dans la rue partout
les politiques parce que ce jour-là
les maliens oncle à samson la sincérité
de 2 en france mais lorsqu'on a empêché
la blâmer de la traque d'al mls de
l'inattention qu'est-ce qui se passe et
comme par hasard les théories centre et
dans ce sanctuaire ils se sont préparés
pendant deux ans pendant ce temps
l'armée français qui n'était pas prévu
d'être au sol anna qu'ils interdisent à
l'armée malienne de l'athlé au sol il
emmène 4000 militaires ok mais si c'est
pas avec l'autorisation de nord-mali
4000 militaires ce n'était pas plus par
par l'opération cvc qui a été dit au
mali ce n'est pas ça un milliard de
francs cfa par jour tout le reste est ce
que vous savez qu'ils assimilent guitare
pour la petite histoire fait partie des
officiers que bloquer à la porte de
kidal à
les unités spéciales ils ont pris année
fils il s'apprêtait à donner de la
société dans les phrases sont bloqués
qu'est ce que vous faites maintenant que
vous leur demander de partir non nous ne
l'ont pas demandé de passer canicule
pacs
ce qui s'est passé d'une certaine
pression de la barre 2d autorités la rue
pas du tout on a vu les pancartes j'aime
fleurir les brancards de veiller plus
tard c'est eux qui ont dit le 3 juin et
le 10 juin ah si un nouveau gouvernement
qu'ils vont quitter le mali au motif que
le mali s'apprêterait à discuter avec
les théories ce set la raison avancée
vous avez un accord de défense avec où
vous décidez d'en sortir vous ne vous
avisez pas si les médias qu'on apprend
par un sommet des dieux c'est celle de
plaisance française vient tout de go
annoncé ce jour d'un autre président l'a
dit monsieur le président ce n'est pas
comme ça deuxièmement nous nous savons
que les deux forces terroristes au sahel
c'est al-qaïda
egis et les gestes les 70 % à 80 % de
nos progrès ça vienne d'al qaîda toutes
les emprises ou et al qaîda les français
disent qu'ils les laissent il part se
concentrer dans la zone de zone afrique
c'est une façon d'aider au mieux on vous
livre al qaîda l'accord qui nous lie en
le rayon faire ils divorcent en bonne et
due forme nous avons proposé une vertu
de l'accord le medal utile voire c'est
tellement naturel de renverser le régime
en ont parlé à personne et maintenant à
lui à un moment donné il se serait
énervé ils se sont mis à insulter nos
autorités de l'ambassade se livrent à
des activités subversives ici c'est pour
ça vous lui avez demandé bâclé qui
divise les maliens lorsqu'ils sortent
pour de façon injurieuse adressée au
président de la transition chef de
l'état malien nous avons dit que c'en
est trop surtout qu'on subodorait qui
préparait un plan pour vous renversez
vous c'était très clair vous il s'est
renversé le gouvernement toutes les
manoeuvres qui se faisait c'est pour
renverser tous ses discours la segunda
illégitime issus des deux coups de
maillet un gouvernement issu d'un coup
d'état mais l'ont félicité on attendait
roland des macros dire qu'ils ont fait
en trois mois plus que l'ancien
gouvernement qu'ils ont soutenu à bout
de bras jusqu'à sa chute et menace les
mêmes disent ce que les douanes en
baisse et oui ils ont fait en trois mois
plus que le dos de l'enfant 7 mai sur
calcutta après dix neuvième à l'issue de
deux coups d'état simplement passer à
sing it as a dit les maliens centaines
de vivres depuis 13 ans est ce qu'on ne
va pas essayer autre chose nous avons
décidé de diversifier nos partenaires et
partent les soldats français qu'est ce
que vous faites comment vous allez vous
en sortir comment vous couvrez ce vide
qu'il laisse mais le vide de toutes les
façons ils ont commencé à le créer ils
ont quitté les bas de tessalit ils ont
quitté les bas des finales il se
préparait à quitter go à ton peuple
isolé c'est comme tombouctou mais ces
bases là il fallait que les occupent est
ce que vous vous occupez que nous allons
les occuper au nous en avons occupé déjà
il va y avoir une période de vide mais
il n'y a pas de vide où nous avons déjà
occupé cette base avec les moins que
nous avons nous avons la même arme et le
leadership a changé nous sommes
réorganisés
on dit aux africains aucun état ne peut
vivre sans l'aide de ses doigts ça fait
deux ans aucun appui budgétaire à noter
on ne vous a pas versé déjà pas ederson
et pendant ces deux ans on est unis les
salaires on a augmenté les salaires on a
équipé l'armée l'argent 10 ou plus que
les 30 dernières années l'argent vient
d'où ça vient du mali là on parle de la
présence des mercenaires de wagner sont
ils là les mercenaires de wagner et
qu'est ce que vous leur donner en
échange comment vous ne nuit ni
travaillons avec des coopérants us dans
le cadre d'investissements vous avez
signé avec une société privée ou avec
l'état a voulu nous nous travaillons
avec l'état russe nous nous complaisons
poutine dit nous ne commentons pas les
propos d'autres chefs d'état du
journaliste d'autres commentateurs on a
vu aussi des avions cargo a atterri un
des hélicoptères neufs qui sortait nous
avons les uns structure discussions avec
nous des officiers ses partenaires mais
on n'a pas caché ses partenaires non le
mot vadel c'est les français qui lui
disent nous on connaît pas de voeckler
qu'est ce qui vous donne les russes la
coopération russe et pas seulement les
russes comme je voulais dire on va
arriver aux jeux ne sont pas seulement
avec les russes et à qui d'autre on sait
qu'ils ont des problèmes géostratégiques
la russie nous personne ne va nous
entraîner dans un combat qui n'est pas
le nôtre nous est ce ça sécurise et
notre population on obtient avec la
russie qui est un partenaire stratégique
depuis 1960 qui a formé 80% de nos
officiers pas le passé amadou toumani
toure il a fait sa formation à lusigny
ben dhaou a fait sa formation a réussi à
6009 appel à l'uci donc aujourd'hui vous
êtes aidés par les russes comment vous
les payez on les paie pas l'argent des
maliens vous n'avez pas donné de mines
aurizon mais on n'est pas dans ce jeu là
ça c'est des pros c'est qu'on nous fait
supposer même qu'on donne une mine mais
ce nos biens on peut pas nous interdit
et rien ne vaut la sécurité des maliens
tout ce qu'il faut de bonnes et si les
français avaient juré franju où les
dédouane les aides et on nous tue et on
inocule comme je dis le du pétainisme
staline la défaite vous attendez à plus
qu'elles ne peuvent rien ça l'europe
sans la france ça fait deux ans qu'on
tient debout ça fait deux ans qu'on
occupe la fetwa - nous avons préparé
pendant six mois la grande offensive à
partir du 28 décembre et du 28 décembre
à aujourd'hui nous avons détruit plus de
battre terroriste parce qu'avant il
enlevait des éléments allaient attaquer
des petites chaque point à l'attaqué des
douanes et des eaux du doubs on est allé
aux kabyles terrorisme pour détruire
l'espace que vous gagner du terrain nous
gagnons l'été et sur les délais ce que
vous avez déjà blessé grave et un
village et qu'on appelle qui est dans le
cercle de niono qui était occupé depuis
deux ans ça vient d'être libéré vous
avez guinée qui vient d'être libéré vous
avez les populations reviennent les
populations revient on a 350
réfugiés depuis plus de neuf ans en
quelques mois 50100 retourner en deux
semaines 20000 son rythme volontairement
est-ce que vous pourrez tenir ses
positions est-ce que vous en avez les
moyens aujourd'hui sans l'armée
française comment vous allez
rien n'existe les princesses étaient
déjà partis je vous dis barnes est venu
se substituer à serval en disant que
l'europe accusait de contenir le
terrorisme ce n'est plus de le détruire
d'aider l'armée a monté en puissance et
enfin aider les populations faire du
social là aussi c'est un essai que
l'armée n'est pas monté en puissance au
premier ministre il ya plusieurs
partenaires vous avez dit la chine et
partenaire aujourd'hui la chine un
personnel bien entendu nous ne le
cachons pas nous ne parlons pas de tous
nos partenaires matière de défense comme
les francophones la fixation sur la
russie ces propos long de la rue c'est
que la chine est généralement fait des
échanges en matière des mines là aussi
vous avez pas donné de carrés miniers
comment vous pc et à l'arrivée est-ce
que ça doit intéresser quelqu'un comment
est ce qu'on trouve l'argent dans notre
pays pour nous équiper pour nous qu'on
perd des mines qu'on perd de l'argent
cash qu'on fait avec de l'or combelles
du diamant tout ce qui nous appartient
légalement ce n'est pas la fermeture il
ya des sociétés occidentales qui sont là
qui exploite les mines personne n'en
parle je n'ai jamais dit que c'est des
1000 qu'on a donné à des
soumissionnaires j'ai dit même si on le
fait qu'est ce qu'il ya de mal dans sa
mais le premier ministre sont un certain
nombre à se poser la question à savoir
maintenant les français sont partis
est-ce que vous allez vous en sortir
nous militairement nous allons nous en
sortir non plus toutes les dispositions
nous allons assurer la sécurité de notre
population déjà il ya des résultats sur
le terrain je viens de vous battre dans
le passé pour la première fois ya une
inversion il n'ya pas d'émigrer à bléré
tony chez eux monsieur premier ministre
pourquoi est ce que vous faites d'objets
des sanctions de la cedeao pourquoi vos
voisins avec qui vous commercer avec qui
vous êtes dans un même organisme vous
sanctionne au point de vous fermer les
portes il ya une contradiction
fondamentale entre la sidérurgie
la cedao veut ramener les élections
alain pluss purement électorales pour ne
pas dire électoralistes maintenant si
vous voulez qu'il n'y a pas de coups de
temps que vous vous attaquer aux causes
de l'insurrection ce qu'on veut nous
amener pendant cinq ans a fait venir
personne à 10,5 en cinq ans c'est une
suggestion une proposition venue des
actionnaires aujourd'hui on peut faire
combien de temps aujourd'hui nous avons
sur la table des discussions nous avons
des chiffres en tête qui doivent être
discutées avec la cedeao on le leur a
dit qu'elle d'élèves ont réfusé ils ont
dit maintenant comme il y avait un
projet de vous renversez quand vous nous
avez donné l'occasion on va faire un an
baroin dans 10-12 allait tomber
maintenant qu'ils ont constaté qu'on
n'est pas tombé ils vont venir on va
discuter en tournoi africain va trouver
une solution ne peux pas vous dire
aujourd'hui donc là pour l'instant vous
êtes ouverts à la négociation avec la
cedeao absolument comment vous arrivez à
survivre avec ses sanctions mais
aujourd'hui est vraiment vous pensez que
c'est dur et je viens de vous le dire
qu'on a inoculé chez les africains les
villes de la défaite est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on ne doit pas arriver à
une à assoupir un peu les positions ce
que mais nous nous sommes d'accord pour
les assouplir on ne peut pas nous
conduire au suicide la cedao veut qu'on
organise des élections ça nous attaquer
aux sources du soulèvement ça fait
quatre coups d'état moins de 30 ha
pourquoi pas ça ne règle pas le problème
de fond la démocratie ne sera même pas
aux élections c'est ce que j'essaie de
faire et deuxièmement quand vous voulez
sur un état de droit vous le souhaitez
minimum de doigts aucune disposition de
la cedeao n'a pris un embargo aucune
disposition de la banque centrale des
états de la fusion n'a plus ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire il ya la
convention des nations unies sur les
pays sans littoral qui interdit un
embargo contre un pays sans littoral
comment vous voulez violé les règles
communautaires les règles
internationales les règles nationaux
pour découvrir tous les états des droits
moi je voulais juste te renverser le
régime a amené des douze ans et
aujourd'hui devant la cour de justice je
promets mini certains disent que c'est
vous le problème que vous avez un projet
que vous avez un programme vous avez une
ambition présidentielle à la fin de tous
et 6,2 répondez vous aujourd'hui j'ai
une ambition
c'est de réaliser la mission que le
président de la transition
m'a confié pour conduire le gouvernement
vous rasez pas le matin en pensant que
nous servent à l'action
chacun suit son destin dieu a créé les
conditions pour que le plus encore sa
confiance mais vous ne serez pas
candidat par ailleurs je ne rentre pas
dans ce débat nous nous voulons d'abord
sortir du pays lassés du mali est tombé
couchies et billy nous voulons les
soigner le fera soit le fud marché mais
vous vouliez pas le faire sans vos
voisins mais nos voisins et vous êtes
fâché avec vos voisins mais nos voisins
n'est pas fiable qu'ils ont compris de
gladiator le centre de gravité de notre
pouvoir à doite le peuple le jour où le
peuple n'est pas d'accord avec nous nous
tirons les conséquences les autres
dirigeants ils avaient peur de parler
parce quand tu parles quand la france
est fâché tu ne seras plus rien nous
avons une dizaine explique à notre
peuple si le peuple du 2 mai qu'il n'est
plus d'accord avec nous l'année montrent
les conséquences un peu plus est libre
et nous allons les libérer aurait
terminé là dessus monsieur le premier
ministre nous arrivons au terme de cet
entretien merci monsieur le premier
ministre de nous avoir reçus l'actualité
continue sur france 24 et rfi
[Musique]
voilà donc pour l'entretien exclusif qui
a accordé à le premier ministre malien
choguel maïga à notre confrère des refi
alain foka un entretien que vous avez
donc pu suivre sur france 24 avec à mes
côtés cyril payen cyril vous avez
couvert pour france 24 l'actualite et
maliennes de ces derniers mois d'abord
on joint dans la bouche du premier mais
ça ne fait aucun doute le départ
français aujourd'hui n'aurait pas été
contraint par les autorités maliennes il
résulte d'un choix français et un
abandon en fait le premier ministre de
la transition je gueule maïga qui est un
habitué des diatribes on peut dire même
qu'il y aille querelle très profonde
avec son avec le ministre les à base
étrangère jean yves le drian ce n'est
pas récent il est droit dans son costume
dans cette interview qui est quand même
assez rare parce que ça sa voix est rare
sur les médias internationaux oui un
abandon ce ne sont pas les maliens qui
ont qui ont versé le premier sans enjeu
direct c'est quand le président macron
le 10 juin dernier à acter ce
redimensionnement de ce changement de
stratégie mais aussi le 2 le changement
d'effectif de cette opération barragan
qui avait fait date le hand septembre
d'après le premier ministre du
gouvernement de transition donc héritier
d'un deuxième putsch rappelons le tout
de même et bien à la tribune des nations
unies par les mêmes indices et les voilà
c'est le sait lui-même choguel maïga qui
avait qualifié d' abandon en plein vol
donc il a et il est c'est un très très
bon orateur il a des éléments de langage
qu'on a bien retenu le virus de la
défaite inoculé par la tradition
française africa le virus même du
pétainisme on va très loin dans l'est
dans les dents les symboles et puis il a
re venu sur les thèmes très important
dans cette interview sur ce qu'il a
appelé
la mère des fautes la mère des fautes
c'est l'incompréhension lors de
l'opération serval le début de
l'intervention en janvier 2013 des
oeuvres d aider et des soldats français
le 2e rep le régiment étranger
parachutiste la légion étrangère qui
saute sur bouctou à l'époque le mali a
demandé de la dette de la france est la
france et est acclamé mais il y à une
incompréhension pour des raisons
stratégiques quand la ville de kidal
libéré et que les forces françaises
empêchent les femmes à les forces
maliennes de pénétrer dans cette grande
ville du nord ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on ressent encore aujourd'hui dans
les villes du mali ce traumatisme
cette incompréhension et qui est
largement exploité surexploités même par
le discours panafricaniste souverainiste
qui est très en vogue aujourd'hui dans
les rues de bamako je leur ai dis bien
les rues de bamako parce que ce n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui cette
appréhension cette appréciation du
départ des français n'est pas vécue de
la même manière à bamako c'est 13 ans
prix montent alizés très vocal que dans
le reste du pays puisqu'il ya plus
d'incertitudes dans le nord notamment
dans les régions de l'azawad les régions
près de manière où les touareg pardon
sont près de prédominant donc il est
revenu sur ces éléments très très
détaillée très très à l'aise et puis en
accusant en croit évidemment la france 2
devrait à la partition et ça c'est pas
nouveau du tout dans son nouveau dans ce
discours souverainiste d'avoir 20 la
partition du mali en creux ne vouloir
soutenir le nord les populations touareg
contre contre bamako il va un peu plus
loin tout de même puisque l'on a on a
parlé de delà de l'abandon mais il y là
il va il revient sur cet incident qui a
vu l'expulsion il ya quelques semaines
de jeu est le meilleur l'ambassadeur de
france et l'ambassadeur de france très
violent puisque en termes d' ugly betty
quand on donne 72 heures à un
ambassadeur pour quitter les lieux c'est
qu'il ya une faute grave là il n'y a pas
de faute grave mais là il va plus loin
puisque le chef du gouvernement accuse
l'ambassadeur d'avoir fomenté dit il je
le cite
des actions subversives sur doute à
renverser le gouvernement de transition
alors il n'a pas de preuves pour étayer
ce genre de d'allégations mais
effectivement ça va loin il est tout à
fait droit dans son costume de chef de
la diatribe anti française au mali voilà
pour les accusations portées par choguel
maïga envers l'armée française alors on
va y revenir chacune de ces accusations
d'abord la première ce viol de
souveraineté par l'armée française qui
aurait empêché les forces armées
maliennes de pénétrer dans kidal et ce
faisant et bien de mettre un terme à
cette insurrection fomenté notamment par
les rebelles de l'azawad eux qui
voulaient proclamé l'indépendance du
nord du mali qu'en est il mais justement
c'est la question de 2,2 de fomenter
l'idée de séparatisme et en mélangeant
les terroristes et les rebelles du ebéné
là qui étaient aux signataires des
accords d'alger il y avait à l'époque on
s'en souvient des ministres qui étaient
venus à à bamako dont qu'il a fait et
refait un peu l'histoire il accuse
d'ailleurs la fois la france d'avoir
imposé la table des négociations
des personnalités non représentative de
ses mouvements aux ailes effectivement
tout ton il en fait c'est le seul
discours très populiste il le n'ayons
pas peur des mots du gouvernement de
transition de fuite en avant on utilise
tous les éléments qui sensibilise une
partie la population malienne à tort ou
à raison donc il ya ces questions sur
les vérités sur le terrain là c est la
seule certitude c'est qu'il ya
effectivement une fatigue aussi sur le
terrain vécue par les populations
civiles sur la dimension de l'opération
barkan le d2 le déploiement logistique
de drones d'avion et le les résultats
peut-être y at-il une erreur de
communication là aussi au delà prêt de
l'état major et des autorités françaises
sur les vins résultats tangibles mais
concrètement les chips et 25 mille morts
ce temps au burkina faso niger et mali
plus de 10000 depuis 2015 c'est beaucoup
c'est beaucoup trop c'est pour ça que ce
genre d'éléments de langage et bien
fonctionne dans les rues de bamako en ce
moment puisqu'il ya des manifestations
très importantes le même show guelma et
gars le 14 janvier dernier avait
participé à une des plus grosses
manifestations un grand rassemblement
du gouvernement de transition pour pro
de grande transition avec des dizaines
de milliers de gens dans les rues il
était apparu en treillis camouflage donc
le message était assez clair on soutient
les militaires sur l'inefficacité
prétendu de cette lutte antiterroriste
dont chogal mag affuble la france pour
lui les français auraient délibérément
laissés livrés d'une certaine manière à
al qaïda au maghreb islamique des pans
entiers du territoire malien pour se
concentrer sur cette zone des trois
frontières voilà si c'est exact là c'est
un petit peu dur aussi c'est un peu
réducteur il fait référence au sommet de
de peau du g5 celle le g5 sel c'est
cette coalition militaire qui roule qui
regroupe le mali le niger le burkina
faso la mauritanie et le tchad auprès du
président français et ses lacs
évidemment ce qui a été qualifié d'
abandon très très vite il s'agissait de
ceux de se recentrer vous leviez didier
sur les affidés du groupe etat islamique
c'est-à-dire la zone des trois
frontières où il ya encore des actions à
l'oeuvre cela a été vu comme indépendant
puisque il ya eu ce road issus du
dimensionnement barkan qui est arrivé
nous y étions avec le transfert aux
forces maliennes de tessalit tu la halle
enclave l'emprise la plus au nord au
nord par dont près de la frontière
algérienne de kidal et puis ensuite de
tombouctou ce tout cela est vécu comme
un affront un abandon maintenant tu ta
sont le divorce est consommé il l'a dit
d'ailleurs c'est un divorce c'est
terminé les français eux partent et il a
dit qu'il allait et le ben ali était
libre et souverain pour diversifier ses
aides donc ses partenaires notamment les
russes choguel maïga accuse aussi la
france d' ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures du mali en ayant pris
position contre ces coups d'état il va
vous l'avez dit jusqu'à accuser
l'ambassadeur d'avoir fomenter un
renversement du pouvoir actuel malien
oui ce qui est curieux c'est que ça n'a
jamais été avancée comme éléments pour
étayer ou justifié ce renvoi de
l'ambassadeur il s'agissait surtout des
les éléments langage utilisé par le quai
d'orsay le chef de la diplomatie
française je relève le drian qu'il
disait insulté un gouvernement de
transition en creux le l'ambassadeur
était la victime de c2c acrimonie de ses
diatribes en europe paris bamako là il
va un peu plus loin il n'a pas été
beaucoup plus loin d'ailleurs pour
donner des preuves tangibles mais on est
aussi dans une guerre d'information
d'éléments de langage et bien pour dire
effectivement le représentant français
et c'est une accusation assez grave tout
de même et bien mener des échanges inter
ci verse iv qu'il allait renverser le
gouvernement pareil pour wagner le
groupe des paramilitaires sulfureuse
dont on dit hélas ses preuves contre
preuve les français les américains
avancent plusieurs centaines d'hommes
peut-être un millier personnellement je
n'en ai pas vu mais aussi la rhétorique
en face on le voit ailleurs dans
d'autres pays ou aux vagues l'air qui
est le bras armé de la diplomatie russe
et bien et très actif et bien c'est le
déni absolu nous nous traitons comme
depuis de nombreuses années de manière
bilatérale avec la coopération russe
nous avons des coopérants et des
militaires russes certainement pas de
wagner il a même le show d'elle je vais
le méga affirme d'ailleurs que wagner
c'est un mot inventé par les français il
n'y a pas que la russie d'ailleurs dit
il il cite notamment la chine parmi les
partenaires du mali mais on le sent
quand même extrêmement gênée à l'heure
de répondre aux éventuelles rétribution
des contreparties qui serait donnée à
ces pays extérieurs qui viendraient en
aide au mali on a évoqué évidemment la
question des mines et là il n'y a pas de
réponse claire c'est notre affaire pour
autant il ne répond pas aux maliens qui
eux sont en droit de s'interroger
puisque ce sont bien les actifs malien
les actifs malien et puis forcément les
carrés miniers ce que tu es très bien
évoqué par alain foka c'est à dire en
fait les contreparties aux
paramilitaires les chinois très présent
nous étions il ya quelques semaines à
bamako l'ambassadeur chinois
nouvellement arrivée 10 est en avance un
français parfait d'ailleurs il faut le
saluer tout de même que les chinois le
pékin était prête à intercéder dans la
crise malienne où prennent place à la
cedeao pour le vcc ça aux sanctions donc
on sent bien qu'à une mainmise
effectivement de ses nouveaux
partenaires nommément la russie et la
chine mais la turquie n'est pas très
loin non plus donc des nouveaux
partenaires une nouvelle manière de voir
la mondialisation qui est parfaitement
t'embrasser de manière très à l'aise par
le premier ministre de transition mais
effectivement pas de réponse claire
quant il s'agit c'est contrepartie on
sait que daguenière par exemple ne
travaille jamais sans contrats miniers
alors il y en a t'il on ne sait pas on
ne sait qu'hier géologue proche de
bagnères qui est écumée le centre et le
sud
du mali mais c'est parole contre parole
c'est une guerre informationnelle quant
aux chinois ils sont déjà très nombreux
hommes et lyon les voit beaucoup à
bamako donc on peut penser que chacun y
trouve son compte que ce soit opaque ou
non que gouvernement un mois moyens que
le gouvernement soit comptable de sa
population aussi est une autre affaire
merci cyril ça y est vous qui couvrent
et à l'actualité malienne pour france24
voilà donc pour cet entretien accordé
par le premier ministre bat lien choguel
maïga